so here you go and it really also shows
that you know men are judged for the
women that they keep around men are
judged for who they associate with now
Dylan also took a meme so this is a meme
of modern day marriage right there's guy
the chick the chick and
then the guy to wife her and so now he
put Logan Paul wow this guy is like 10-0
he's like 10-0 and I guess this guy has
also I saw some tweets where I guess he
dated a hoe too and he was a little bit
mad because he's like when everyone was
tweeting
um pictures of my chick with everybody I
didn't block no cease and desist I just
took it would you say it's an unmanly
thing to block somebody and send a cease
and desist letter I don't know I can't
imagine